this is valentine holmes jets running
back kick returner
catching punts and holding punts that's
three
here's four
can you do it valentine holmes yes he
can but here's the real question chris
sims can he do five can he do five he
did oh my god oh yeah that was oh he had
the kick he had the hacky sack move at
the end to save it i like that valentine
holmes getting it done whether or not
that means he can be on the week one
roster remains to be seen but he's got
that flexibility the more you can do
for a football team the better chance
you have of making the team and these
guys we're going to talk about now in
today's draft chris these are guys who
uh have no worries about making the team
because they make up the best positional
groups in the entire national football
league any positional group you want to
go to you get to do it and there's a
trivia question coming i guess since
they're not giving me the question
today's the day that i have to try to
answer it what do you got that's right
you got to deal with me okay in lieu of
the xfl releasing some of their you know
nfl embl or xfl emblems excuse me okay
here's the questions tommy maddox won
the only xfl mvp in 2001
what team did he play for mike florio
he played for the team that was in los
angeles
but they the la express was the usfl
team is it enough to say la i i i will i
will
nope it wasn't i checked with the judges
sorry the russian judge says you have to
explain the full team sorry
wait a minute i i didn't get a chance to
guess i i at least give me a guess all
right give me a guess give me the name
of the team
wait a minute
wait a minute alex trebek gives the
contestants more time it was the la
galaxy no that's the soccer team they're
close see there's an x in it there is an
accident the the the l well it's not the
express right that's the usfl team no
right the extreme
the la extreme yeah los angeles making
that extreme no i'm not i wouldn't have
remembered but stats gave me this one
and you lost sorry
i got half of it right i got the city
right yes yes you did you definitely did
he would go on to play for the steelers
until he was supplanted by cordell
stewart in 2002. all right go ahead and
then and then he got injured in 2004 and
that opened the door to ben
roethlisberger's career and allen fannik
at the time said i don't want some
rookie quarterback out there they went
on to be 15-1 that year go ahead okay
you're done now be quiet let's get to
the draft here we go and then he broke
3-d played in the afc championship game
with three broken toes and then bill
cower said he didn't have any broken
toes go ahead thank you very much okay
you done now thank you thank you okay
this is this is a this is a good i mean
it's a good draft it really is because
there's a lot of options and it's really
hard to pinpoint you know exactly who
that one group is but i gotta go with
this group i think is the most dominant
group that i saw in football last year
as one unit i'm gonna have to go with
the indianapolis colts offensive line i
mean they were special last year you
know what they did in indianapolis you
remember right remember right they did
mike
they built a wall a big blue wall that's
what they did it's so big it's gonna be
the greatest wall you've ever seen and
it was an awesome wall it really was i
mean that offensive line whether it's
quentin nelson costanzo at left tackle
it's the one of the best in all of
football dominant in both areas of the
game i mean truly a wall in front of
andrew luck passing the football where
he could sit back there and pat the ball
three and four times and wait for t.y
hilton to get open 60 yards down the
field and then the holes they opened up
in the run game i mean they
uh that one unit is responsible for
turning around an organization and
that's where you know you got to give
chris ballard uh a lot of credit for
building that and then of course frank
reich and his offense to go along with
it with fitting the skill set of the
guys but i i got to go with that as the
number one unit in football as far as a
dominant dominant unit
and of course jim irsay for paying for
that wall that's right yep he paid for
that and they and and they hope that
this year the wall doesn't become a
series of slats that are easily uh
penetrable
all right uh i'm gonna i'm gonna stay
with the colts uh week three pre-season
opponent the chicago bears the bears
linebackers and you know they they they
get overlooked because linebacker is not
really as as sexy a position as it used
to be because offenses throw the ball so
much more but these linebackers are
versatile they can rush the passer they
can get the ball carriers they can cover
receivers if need be you've got khalil
mack danny trevath and roquan smith
leonard floyd they have invested draft
capital they've invested draft picks via
trade they've invested money to make
this unit the best in the nfl and you
know they've got that history with mike
singletary and and dick butkus and and
now here we go oh and brian urlacher got
to mention him recent hall of famer but
here we go with these four linebackers
for the bears defense you know there's a
concern that with vic fangio gone that
defense could take a dip it's the
players ultimately and chuck pagano who
was good enough a defensive coordinator
in baltimore to become the head coach of
the colts
he he's he's got the best defense right
now that he's ever had to deal with and
those four linebackers are the heart of
it yeah i agreed mike i mean they were
on my list too i didn't know whether if
i wanted to make it like a defensive
line because you know khalil mack's like
a outside linebacker slash defense end
but that was a better way to put it
because it is a special group they have
depth there but the three studs at the
the forefront roquan smith who i think
is going to be an absolute superstar he
looks even better to me this year than
he did last year and you mentioned
leonard floyd and of course khalil mack
is really other than aaron donald the
best defensive player in the game when
healthy so i'm not mad at you there they
were certainly on my list okay i'm gonna
go to one
that never gets the attention that it
deserves
and i understand why it doesn't get the
attention because there's some other
people on the the team that that deserve
a lot of attention but the patriots
secondary
that's where i'm gonna go the patriots
secondary often overlooked you heard me
say earlier in the week they can't they
played a defensive game plan against the
kansas city chiefs that nobody in the
history of the nfl has played they
played man-to-man they play male or
man-to-man than any team in football the
last two or three years steph allen
stefan gilmore is certainly one of the
three best corners in football devin
mccourty is one of the best safeties in
football i mean he's such a good safety
and he can play corner too but it's the
depth it's the patrick chungs that's the
jason mccordy's it's the jc jackson uh
who's going to be a phenomenal corner as
we continue to go they can match up with
so many different styles of offenses
because of the depth and i don't want to
sit here and just continue to name names
but they have size speed small quick
jitterbug type guys they really have it
everything you need in the secondary to
match up with any receiving core that
comes to town and they get overlooked
too much and they're one of the best in
football yeah and look i have to give
you credit for that one because
ultimately they were able to shut down
the group that is my next pick we spend
so much time worrying about whether or
not jared goff is going to step up and
become a franchise quarterback we worry
about todd gurley's knee the rams
receiving core is the best in the nfl
and you know the vikings have the top
two guys in stephon diggs and adam
thielen but i don't know who the hell
number three is and i don't think they
know who number three is you've got
robert woods brandon cooks and cooper
cup and i think that team changed last
year when cooper cup suffered his knee
injury you get those three guys healthy
and they'll make up for what todd gurley
can't do and they'll make jared goff
look better than maybe he otherwise is
and and those are the top three top to
bottom most dangerous receivers in the
national football league and i know the
depth chart goes deeper than that but if
you go three deep with top flight guys
like that you have a great receiving
core and i think the rams have the best
receiving core in the nfl because of
those three guys they're definitely in
that conversation you're respon i mean
you're right about that and you're right
about your take on cooper cup there that
changed their offense and what they want
to do that was a blow to their football
team certainly
i'll just because i want to win the
draft you take them over the browns
receivers right now you know landry
odell beckham jr jaylen then who then
who richard
i know some other guys that are not
happy antonio callaway yeah well you're
not going to say him it's going to be
rashard higgins or jalen strong so i'm
just throwing out i'm proving i'm not on
the falcons receivers julio jones
mohammed's anu and calvin ridley it's a
good one yeah just throwing it out there
i want to win the dragon
yeah yeah but yeah i know i know you
know they'd like to get rid of muhammad
sununu if they could too you know that
okay all right here we go are we allowed
to say that we're allowed to say that
yeah
you said it i didn't i didn't i said so
okay go ahead here we go oh all right um
gosh i don't know which one i want to go
with but i think i'm
i'm going to this is a tough one it is a
tough one i don't know where i'm going
to go with the ravens secondary okay i'm
going with the ravens secondary with the
addition of earl thomas
i just go
watch out they can match up with anybody
in football a lot like we just talked
about with the patriots secondary earl
thomas got two rockets up his butt still
mike in the back end he can play center
field as good as anybody in the game
then you get marlin humphrey who showed
signs of being a shutdown corner last
year i think he continues to grow that
way jimmy smith okay brandon carr and
then
tony jefferson a guy that just goes
unnoticed in football a little bit but
is it
exceptional in the box strong safety but
has covered skills too he's not just the
thumper and they got depth behind all of
that too i really look at that as being
one of the premier groups position
groups and football this coming year
yeah man you really like the secondary i
know right i went two in a row i didn't
want to do it but i i just felt that
strong about it
yeah i okay i i'm gonna go uh offensive
i went defense with round one offense
with round two and and this is a team
that you know how i feel about this team
last year when everyone was writing them
off i stayed with the seattle seahawks
all year long and the seattle seahawks
have the best running back group in the
national football league especially when
you consider that their quarterback will
run the football so he's part of it as
well chris carson is holding off rashad
penny there's some indication that chris
carson is actually separating from the
first round pick in 2017 or 2018 rather
than a seventh round pick in 2017 had a
great season last year penny played well
when he had the choice they still have
cj precise hanging around on the roster
i don't know that he's still going to be
there much longer jd mckissick is a guy
that they can't even wedge into the
running back position anymore but i
think carson
penny and russell wilson who
unofficially is a running back for the
seattle seahawks because he will run it
when he needs to that's the best running
back group in the nfl it is pretty
strong um oh you know again i want to
win the draft we're just not sure about
rashad penny who i have very high
expectations for this year and i agree
with you it looks like just reading
between the lines and what you see it
looks like chris carson is just getting
better and becoming more dominant in his
role uh so i hear you there it is an
impressive group you know there is the
browns running back situation but kareem
hunt's not going to be available there's
the 49ers out there but you know who we
missed mike i mean cowboys all line that
was one that i was kind of contemplating
there and the jaguars secondary or
d-line you could go jaguar secondary or
d-line there those are other ones that
were just on my list
yeah and look there's plenty of great
groups out there i mean i was even
thinking of throwing the washington
quarterbacks into the mix because
i i look the rest of the team is a
dysfunctional mess for the most part but
case keenum i love dwayne haskins i
believe in and colt mccoy can come in
and get it done for you as needed he's
just not healthy and how many teams go
three deep with guys that you feel that
strongly about yeah some have two
but the washington's got three guys that
can come in and play and i don't mean
the rest of the players are
dysfunctional i just mean the organ yeah
yeah that's not looking great there
right now big cat said last week
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
the saints quarterbacks that's another
good one they have they might have three
right now just to throw it out there
yeah i don't know about teddy
bridgewater though i hope he turns it
around but it just something's not right
there dysfunctional shows go over their
their time limit which we we're doing
but uh uh we'll take a break now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports